yeah we're ready okay let's just get
back in to get back of the horse what
we're doing yesterday yeah we were
different she contributed differences
and I said to get to this very simple
result the Derby of sign is called the
tribute because it might have seen a
sign
I was thinking tan and saying sign of
the same time and the derivative of tan
is to remember six squared
anyway to get to these results requires
all this stuff okay so here's what we
did we said we were going through the
textbook approach backwards okay so we
just look at the graphs we thought what
is the gradient look like we got a
general sense of it okay then we looked
at first principles and we use trig
expansions and we break apart Li bits
and all that kind of thing and it worked
out but this is what we got up to
yesterday right I am I gave you this
limit as H approaches zero I said that
this limit was equal to one remember
that and I sort of looked at the graphs
and I was like look it's kind of close
but we don't really know why okay so you
can see that's why I text me to do it in
this order so they get a result and then
that allows you to prove the next bit so
on okay but I think it's less intuitive
so now we've used this result can we
show why it's the case okay
so right now I'm sort of doing two and
three are sort of together okay
so let's do this at the same time you
might want to make a heading which is a
squeeze
so we're picking up we've done four and
five okay which we did five and then
four so now two and three they sort of
do clump together so we're going to do
the birth right now so to start off with
before I explain what the squeeze law is
I want to give to a scenario which is
that this is similar all we did
yesterday right
if you throw three graphs on top of each
other and I'd like you to actually draw
these just roughly if you draw outside
their usual X the straight line okay
like so and then you draw ten which has
okay so I've just drawn a very very
small part of ten the section of this
graph that I'm interested in is the plot
the domain from 0 the axis to PI on Suze
that's just that little bit dpi
okay see where to file - okay so where X
is a cute basically what can you see how
do you describe the growth of each one
just in this little section here so in
fact I'm gonna forget about the rest of
the graphs okay so this is actually the
part that I would like you to have drawn
let's describe these three graphs and
how they are behaving each of the graphs
right there grading is positive you see
that they're all increasing but they're
not all increased you the same rate okay
so for instance sine sine is increasing
but it's increasing at a decreasing rate
does that make sense
increasing at a decreasing rate it's
still going up that's what increasing
means but it's sort of slowing down it's
like you're riding up a hill and you're
like I get tired right so that's what I
mean you might increase in you're still
going forward you're going up but at a
slower and slower rate until in fact
when you get to piyo - you stopped
increasing altogether okay you've just
stopped okay all right yeah that's
that's sine X now what about this
okay exit also increasing but what rate
is it's increasing at it's increasing at
a constant rent right because you could
say like a different check this which
gives me gradient and the gradient is
one and the gradient is always one
forever this line is just decreasing at
the same rate okay so increasing at a
constant okay now lastly tennis also
increasing and you can probably fill in
the gaps here right
it's increasing at an increasing rate
because it's approaching an asymptote
right sorry Frankie it's getting closer
and closer steeper and steeper and
steeper and it never gets there right so
it's going to keep on increasing and
increasing red all the way I put
Sebastian okay that's all right
therefore what I'm going to suggest is
off the back of that idea this
inequality
okay now we're used to having through
society inequalities one things bigger
than another or less than another but
I've got three things here so I want to
get the relationship between all three
sine X right just in this domain sine X
is always going to be less than X and
that's always going to be less than so
I've put these ball in order okay I'm
disregarding zero at the origin because
then this will be true and I'm also
disregarding pile two because this guy
doesn't exist okay all right now keep in
mind where I'm trying to head towards
I'm trying to head towards this this is
the result of trying to establish
because I need it for the first
principles thing right I can't simplify
any further the island so how do I get
from this to this well the star where
I'm going to divide everything through
by side divide everything for myself one
two three pucks so this is a bit like
you know when you've got any inequality
you say 2x is lesson 4 we just solved
this divide both sides by two right then
that's all happy okay now by the way if
I had minus 2x is less than four and so
in the next line I'm going to divide
through by minus two okay
what happens the inequality it changes
directions right so with inequalities
like so with inequalities you'll be
careful it's not an equal sign that
whatever you do to the right left and
right is exactly the same the direction
matters now tell me as I divide through
by sine X so I'm going to get on this
side I'm just gonna get one in the
middle I'm just gonna get explored sine
X and on the right hand side 10 is just
shorthand for sine over clause so when I
divide through by sine I'm going to get
whatever cuz ah
okay now you tell me how can I go then
none of these inequalities are changed
direction
good good I'm very carefully very
carefully restricted the domain here
right and within this domain you can see
it on your graph right all of these are
all positive so we're just doing
positive numbers none of these are
inequalities going on we're dragons
all right now where do I want to go to
from here well I need a limit in here
somewhere right so I'm going to apply a
limit to all of these I'm gonna say
what's the limit as I've got a chair but
these are X is the same as X approaches
zero okay so I'm going to take the limit
of all three of these parts of the
inequality
okay all right now think through with me
um this middle part is basically where I
want to okay so I need to think about
either side what's the limit as X
approaches zero how is this thing
behaving it's just a constant right it's
just one it's always one it doesn't give
a rip what X is doing so it's just one
okay
this living in the middle I'm going to
leave it as it is now what happens on
the right hand side as X approaches zero
what does cause approach you can think
about from either side from a bobble
blood it approaches one because the
graph the claws looks like this right
okay so as I'm approaching zero that
middle part axis of getting closer to
that point there is one okay
so therefore this thing is one what's
approaching whatever 1 which is 1 does
that make sense
yeah can you see why this section is
called the squeeze law or why
mathematicians called invented something
called the square form there's this
thing in the middle here and I'm trying
to work out what's equal to I determine
it's not a bigger than one right
I've also term is very less than 100
what's going on here okay so really what
this means is I've got this unknown
thing and I've got it constrained
between two other things right and these
could be other functions if you like but
just in this case it happens they were
constant okay so if I'm between them but
they're both the same thing that means
that this time here is my result this
limit is not greater than
so I greater than or lesser than either
of them it's equal to one okay so this
part here on this line is called the
squeeze law the unknown value after it's
literally getting squeezed between two
other things that I do know that okay
now because it's not one right this is
useful to me because one is its own
reciprocal okay so therefore I can say
this implies that if I take it upside
down XO 2 sine X sine x over X because
it's approaching one and its reciprocal
is itself right and that's the limit I
was after this here
okay now by the way this important
result right we're using it to prove
these derivatives in that kind of thing
but it's also useful as its own sort of
thing when you're doing limits okay
remember limits was its own idea and
we're thinking about you know once the
limit as X approaches 2 of x squared
minus 4 on X minus 2 by the way what is
it equal to what do you do
factorize the top which would be X minus
2 X plus 2 and then that explains 2
cancels so it's going to be X plus 2 so
that's just war okay now you've looked
at these kinds of things he was familiar
with that right so these are what we
call limits of algebraic expressions
these limits here are similar and
they're the kinds of things you're going
to be expected to recognize as well okay
now I said here that 3 is limit on X and
sine x + tan X as well okay so because X
and sine X and tan X they're all
actually if you like they're all
converging toward the same value okay so
I've got a lot of different ways a lot
of different combinations for how I can
say this limit okay
I can also say I can also say the limit
as X approaches 0 of say X over tangents
right I can say that's equal to it again
the limit as X approaches 0 of 10x over
X or any such combination they are all
equal to 1 okay because they're all
converging at the same point at the same
right okay one more way to say it which
is that all of these things here okay as
I consider them for really really tiny
values if you've got a magnifying glass
out and you zoomed in on the origin okay
we can say that sine X is approximately
equal to X which is approximately equal
to tan X for small values of X
okay so let me just recap because that
was two and thirty three okay
these results here that I've got down at
the bottom number one which we got from
this inequality number two which I got
by just taking the reciprocal three four
and then this reader way of saying it
down here five all of these they're in
the syllabus and in the they're not to
be examined but you need to understand
how they work
sorry I mean this is not to be Jenna
these can okay so you might get give it
a little bit like this
or maybe they might throw five up there
which would have what effect you just
multiply this by 5 you know further
number so they're there things you need
to be real okay so two and number three
squeeze law and limits of all of these